Abby you darken the door of Martin Van
Buren High School a few years ago in
queens new york let's bring our
high-powered highfalutin conversation
down to the people of Martin Van Buren
high school what does janet yellen
statement yesterday mean for the average
American it's a great question tom and
she answered it directly because she was
asked about what is going on in the
economy and she said we're really
focused in on the labor markets and one
of the things that we all have to keep
in mind is this discrepancy between the
reported rate of unemployment that's so
called you three and the u6 and when you
look at the broader measures of
unemployment you see there are so many
people working part-time who'd like to
add some more hours and also the
participation rate is not where we think
it should be meaning a lot of people
have just dropped out of the labor
market and so this is a Fed that is
really focused in on making sure that
the average American is feeling better
than they are right now you've got a
interesting structure and Goldman Sachs
about changing equity calls with
deference in many ways to David costume
to Goldman Sachs adjust your equity
perspective yesterday after the
announcement and then the press
conference the answer tom is really
we've not made adjustments either to our
a global view on the economies or the
markets and the reason is that our chief
economist yon hacias i think has nailed
this question let me interrupt folks ray
dalio Carl Rick adana and I said this
yesterday yon ansias of goldman sachs
nailed this call didn't they Abby they
did in in two ways tom one was what was
the Fed going to do and yon has been of
the point of view for quite a long time
that it wasn't going to be September
December 2015 or maybe sometime in 2016
was more likely but what I think is more
important than a specific all is the
view that we've had on the global
economy basic
the United States which we'd all like to
be more robust is nevertheless one of
the strongest economies in the world
we're the largest economy in the world
so clearly what's happening here matters
a great deal but when we take a look at
the other large economies China for
example the world's second-largest
there's a clear deceleration going on we
also know that Europe is a mixed bag
Germany performing far better than some
of the others and it looks like US
economic growth is one to one-and-a-half
percent higher than it is on in the
other countries in Europe so when we
take a look at what is the central bank
likely to do the idea is that they're
probably better off waiting longer and
and perhaps the risk of waiting too long
in their view is less of a concern then
moving too quickly